more evacuations are underway this
morning as firefighters try to contain a
fast-moving wildfire in Montana new
video shows a man and his father's
desperate attempt to escape the flames
last week in their car justin builtin
and his dad Charlie were in Glacier
National Park when the Hal Ridge fire
exploded in size DeMarco Morgan is
following this story this is incredible
footage DeMarco yeah what a story it is
good morning the high Ridge fire started
with a lightning storm passed through
Glacier National Park more than a week
ago and we spoke with Justin builtin who
says he his father were camping when the
fire began and we're told it wouldn't
spread but a few hours later they were
racing to get out around advise our
inflames Justin builted and his father
frantically tried to escape this is
insane
you can hear the panic in Justin's voice
as he navigates his car down a narrow
mountain trail he can't see just go easy
now explode see the flames that big and
for that far was absolutely terrifying
it was like Sun earthly it was like
driving into hell
milton says he feared for his life as
the dark smoke made seen the road nearly
impossible a fallen tree blocked their
one way out once we got to that downed
tree you know my heart just dropped and
that's when I thought we were dead I
thought there was no way we could back
up through what we've just come through
builtin put the car in reverse driving
back to their lakeside campsite where
they flagged down a boat the car was
destroyed in the fire I just know that
we were lucky wasn't our time to go yet
so there's some higher power that has a
purpose for me and my dad here they are
lucky to be alive both adjusted and his
father didn't suffer any injuries from
the incident the high ridge fire is
still growing and has now burned more
than 78 hundred acres of land and fire
officials say they don't expect it to be
fully contained until November nor what
a story DiMarco you can hear there the
point you're doing great keep going now
encouragement is having the father there
maybe helped in this scenario absolutely